Hi, I'm John Green. Over the last three years
here at Crash Course we've been able to live
our dream of making educational content that
we can release free, for everyone, forever.
But Crash Course isn't actually super cheap
to make, like we've got to pay for the eagle,
and also like animators and editors and educators
and our writers...
We pay for Crash Course partly thanks to the
support of PBS Digital, the public broadcasting
system in the United States, and partly from
advertising, also partly from grants, from
people like Bill Gates.
Thank you Bill Gates.
But a huge portion of Crash Course's budget
comes from people, people like you, who traditionally
have supported us through Subbable.
Without that support we wouldn't have been to grow
the Crash Course videos; we also wouldn't have been
able to start making lesson plans, so that teachers
can better integrate Crash Course into their classrooms.
Unfortunately, we recently found out that
Subbable's payment system is being scrapped
by Amazon. That was a real bummer, but it
was also an opportunity. Because we figured
you know, as long as people are going to have
to re-enter their information anyway, we should
really just join forces with Patreon.
Patreon's very similar to Subbable— you can make
monthly payments to support stuff that you love
so that it can continue to exist. The main
difference is that Patreon is much better
funded, and supported, and has more features,
so in general it's better.
We've known the people who founded Patreon
for many years, they are good people, it is
a good company, and it also makes even more
sense for you to sign up right now because
for the first month they are going to match
every dollar that comes into Crash Course,
so your impact will be doubled. If you're
a Crash Course Subbable subscriber right now
and you have money in your perk bank don't
worry— we're going to keep the site up for
several more months and your money will remain
in your perk bank— but you should spend
it. But we are asking you as soon as possible
to transfer your subscription to Patreon because
this is a kind of scary time for us.
The money that we make from crowdfunding is
very, very important to Crash Course. It's
important not only because your support literally
keeps the lights on around here but also because
Patreon is our only source of funding where
passion matters more than views. Like inevitably
fewer people are going to watch Crash Course
Chemistry than are going to watch, like, Crash
Course The History of Blood and Guts, but
that doesn't mean that Crash Course Chemistry
is less important.
So we're hoping that once again enough people
who can pay a little bit per month to support
Crash Course will choose to do so, so that
all people can have access to it. But of course
we understand that lots of people can't afford
to pay, and that's okay. We want Crash Course
to be there for you. So whether you're able
to help by watching and sharing Crash Course
or by signing up for a monthly pledge at Patreon
we are deeply in your debt.
There are links below to sign up. Thank you
again for watching Crash Course, for being
part of this journey with us, and, as we say
in my hometown, don't forget to be awesome.